and that mean when people come to me
with excuses and stuff I always say to
them you know you got a lot excuses oh
wow you life is hard huh Wow hmm
sometimes tell me come with me for a
second
get my car ride down this street
let's see let's do you right I said do
you want that no that's the point I'm
making as I'm not suggesting it's easier
that you're not suffering but do you
want that I mean you ain't gotta look
for you know it's their suffering going
on right here that's I go down a fifth
and spring you'll see children crawling
in and out of dumpsters for food so what
do you think people under 25 or 30 not
understand about success in Hollywood
maybe they think oh I'll never be that
you know everybody always thinks I'll
never I could never end up like that
which sometimes it's just a matter of
bad you know circumstances piled up and
one to lead someone there and they think
oh I have a safety net it would never
happen to me but the general 25 30 year
old that comes out here with a degree
genes that are the planners call
frustration
there are two things I would address it
with one is the guide joke you know you
know the guy joke tell him your plans or
o or is that John Lennon like this wow
that's a guy joke ok make God laugh tell
him your plans and I mean another thing
I find that were the younger generation
now might have a story of a minister
that's a friend of mine told me he said
he said Bill you know one one day I
stood up in church and I said to my
congregation he said everybody that
wants to go to heaven
stand-up dance and sing hallelujah a
whole church fifteen hundred people come
up and he shouted for five to ten
minutes you got calm him down whoa whoa
okay okay okay okay
said uh my second question everybody
wants to die stand up and sing
hallelujah but I said if I got my third
question is it Howard hell you got to go
to heaven if you don't die see everybody
wants to go to hell
but don't no damn body want to die and
dying for holly was about how do you
resurrect yourself after you're smashed
a couple of thousand times do you buy a
violin plays a little self-pity moments
of having fear everything is and how
great you are and how mean they are and
that could go on for thirty years forty
years or do you take the initiative to
do something that changes that it's like
one or two choices giving up or moving
ahead and a lot of folks just
and these are people have been in the
street 20 years they talk to them oh
well you know how hard it is these damn
agents and these studios and networks
and really hmm it heard of the Internet
yeah but that doesn't then whoever so
podcast know why I don't know how how
could I learn that's too hard but you
expected the results what you're doing
the same thing let's call this sanity so
all you can do is help you figure out
loving caring tell people but not
everybody listens they they just don't
listen they're afraid to jump into the
pond you know it's like today it's a
whole new world in terms of this
industry and say there's a pond and the
success range is over there and a lot of
folks just jump in they can't swim but
the best they can and get to the other
side while they're doing that some of us
put our arm in the water to cool it's a
too deep it's a too warm a lot of waves
out there by the time the pond cools
down and you start moving to the other
side and your little boat there are
signs put up other people who took the
chance and those signs say entry fees
you know why because they deserve it
we over their cowardly thinking they
didn't wait they jumped you know if they
were gonna drown or not they they didn't
know anything they just know that
whatever over there
I'll get some that so I don't have that
I don't want to be here anyway it takes
that kind of desire on my wall in my
office have a picture which is my
favorite favorite picture it's it's an
ostrich or a swan
who's swallowing a frog and the Frog is
halfway down this one's throat this one
problem the Frog has its hands are brown
Smart's squeezing and it smells like and
the title says never give up
you can be down their throat but as long
as you got your hands around that throat
can't swallow
you